Less like sleep and more like suspended animation,
most fish species do spend some time resting.
And like us, if they don’t put in enough
downtime, they try to make up for it later.
Sleep has a simple definition that includes
closed eyelids and a particular brainwave
pattern in the neocortex; as a result, it’s
relatively easy for researchers to determine
when a person, another mammal or a bird is
asleep.
This definition is problematic, however, when
it comes to fish, since they have neither
a neocortex nor eyelids.
As such, researchers have to rely on behavior
observation to determine when they’re napping.
Typically when a fish is “sleeping,” four
characteristics are observed: (1) inactivity
for a long time; (2) a resting posture (like
a droopy tail); (3) a routine (like resting
at the same time, and in the same manner,
each day); and (4) decreased sensitivity to
its environment (hard to arouse).
Different species of fish snooze in different
ways.
For example, tilapia have been observed resting
at the bottom of their habitats, while brown
bullhead catfish were found napping at a 10-30
degree angle along the bottom, with their
tails flat and fins stretched out.
In addition, some species of bass and perch
were seen sleeping on or under logs, while
fish around a coral reef often hide in its
crevices at night
In many fish species, during this period of
rest, lower cardiac and respiratory rates
are observed, as are decreased mouth, gill
and eye movements.
For several, like the bluehead and requiem
shark, the decreased sensitivity to disturbance
is so profound that researchers have been
able to pick them up and haul them toward
the water’s surface without stirring any
reaction.
Interestingly, some fish species never seem
to sleep.
Both mackerel and bluefish swim constantly,
and although they swim less at night than
during the daytime, they remain responsive
to stimuli 24-7.
Another night-owl, the California horn shark,
is far more active at night, although even
during the day it remains responsive to disturbances.
Others that never seem to sleep, but may actually
catch 40 winks now and then, include many
fish that live in large schools.
One theory holds that while some members of
the group have their eyes peeled, others are
able to enter a kind of daydreaming restful
state.
Other fish don’t give any signs of sleeping
when they’re young, but develop a sleep
pattern once they reach adulthood; still others
that normally sleep at night, like the tautog,
suspend any signs of sleeping during periods
of migration and spawning.
Some chichlids and threespine sticklebacks
will forego sleep while their eggs are incubating
– not necessarily to protect them, but to
fan them (thereby providing a continuous supply
of oxygen to the brood).
Some species of sleep-loving fish will work
to catch up on lost sleep.
In a 2007 study, several researchers ruthlessly
pestered a group of zebrafish by alternately
tapping on the aquarium and even piping noise
in through an underwater loudspeaker.
Completely deprived of sleep during their
normal 6 hour dark period, the next day, the
researchers left the tank dark and observed
that the zebrafish were significantly harder
to arouse, and their normal mouth and gill
movements had been cut in half.
Tapping on tanks seems to be a popular method
with fish-sleep researchers, and in 2011,
some NYU biologists used the technique to
determine that cave fish don’t sleep much
when compared with their surface-dwelling
neighbors.
Observing four species of fish all indigenous
to northeast Mexico, a surface-fish species,
Astyanax mexicanu, as well as three cave-dwellers,
Pachón, Tinaja and Molino, the scientists
discovered that the surface fish slept about
4 times more than cave fish (800 minutes in
24 hours compared with 110-250).
Easily as seemingly sadistic (to those of
us who love sleep) as the zebrafish researchers,
the NYU biologists also experimented with
depriving the Mexican fish of sleep – by
moving their containers once every minute.
Sure enough, the fish lost sleep, and like
their zebrafish cousins, they caught up on
it by sleeping more the next day.
Seeking to learn why the cave fish sleep less,
the scientists with the 2011 study then bred
cave fish with surface fish (to observe any
inherited sleep characteristics).
Remarkably, each hybrid inherited the cave
fish’s need for less sleep, and as a result,
the researchers concluded there is a genetic
basis that regulates sleep, and the cave fish’s
gene (requiring less sleep) was dominant.
After a review of over 300 scientific publications,
a panel of 18 scientists and researchers including
representatives of the American Physiological
Society, American Academy of Pediatrics, American
Psychiatric Association and American Geriatrics
Society, prepared a list of new sleep recommendations
for the National Sleep Foundation.
They concluded that newborns should optimally
get 14-17 hours of sleep each day, infants
12-15, toddlers 11-14, preschool kids 10-13,
grammar school kids 9-11, teenagers 8-10,
adults (aged 18-64) 7-9, and older
adults 7-8.